the big news this morning is everyone
woke up and the breaking news
was china has made cryptocurrency and
bitcoin transactions illegal and they
now are pushing all of the bitcoin
miners out of the country
not really that surprising frankly
remember china has done this over and
over and over again our friend over at
john street capital a pseudonymous
account on twitter made this awesome
collage he must have spent hours toiling
away this morning trying to go ahead and
make the collage that shows all of the
different
headlines china bans banks from handling
bitcoin trades bitcoin drops 500 after
more reports china will ban
cryptocurrency exchange beijing bans
bitcoin china clams down on
cryptocurrency speculation bitcoin drops
to 7k as china vows to dispose of local
exchanges they've been saying this over
and over and over again but the market
doesn't nearly care enough because
at some point it just becomes the boy
who cried wolf we were talking about a
decentralized digital technology that
cannot be shut down and cannot be
stopped doesn't matter how authoritarian
or how centrally planned your economy or
your government is they cannot stop this
so what they can do is they can issue
press releases they can issue statements
and they can continue to say that they
are going to stop it or they are going
to shut it down but ultimately they
can't do it and so dylan leclair who's
on the show earlier this week had a
great point this morning he said why did
china
only have to ban facebook and google
once but has to continue to ban bitcoin
over and over again there might be a
lesson there very true if all of a
sudden you have to continuously say
we're banning this we're banning this
we're banning this we're not going to
allow our citizens to do it all
transactions are illegal but the people
don't stop
and you can't shut down the network
maybe you can't actually ban it you can
say it you can talk about it you can
posture
but there's something different about
talking about it and being able to do it
and ultimately what we are watching is
the world is waking up to the fact that
bitcoin is a freedom technology
bitcoin
is anti-ccp
technology the authoritarian
dictatorship the century-planned economy
they don't like technologies that give
freedom and sovereignty to their people
and that's ultimately what bitcoin does
and so regardless of where you are in
the world
there is now an open decentralized
system
the last time we had something like this
it was the internet
and what we saw were the countries that
embraced the internet the countries that
said if there is a technology that can
make our country better we are going to
use it they prospered they were able to
benefit from embracing that open
decentralized network but the countries
who decided not to allow their citizens
to engage in or benefit from the ability
to now communicate or get information
to get the freedom of technology like
the internet they suffered
north korea is a great example they
completely cut off their people from the
internet
it hasn't worked out very well for them
and so the united states would never
have said wow the internet is here the
internet is going to allow other
countries that we may or may not agree
with on certain issues to get a benefit
from it we as the united states should
sit this one out let's not use the
internet because somebody else may
benefit from it no instead what the
united states said was the united states
said if someone's going to benefit from
the internet
we are going to benefit more than anyone
else that is the american spirit that is
the american ethos and values is that we
compete on the global stage if there's a
technology that can be used to make us
better we're gonna use it if there's a
technology that will allow us to create
more jobs more innovation more economic
prosperity we're gonna use it
we don't use regulation or central
planning to try to circumvent the free
market and think that the government
knows better than the market
or the entrepreneurs and the investors
ultimately bitcoin is a free market
technology anyone in the world with an
internet connection can plug into the
open system
and therefore the united states cannot
make the same mistake as china if
china's going to ban it if they're going
to outlaw it if they're going to put
pressure on their citizens and
corporations not to participate in the
ecosystem
thank you
we appreciate you
shooting yourselves in the foot while
the united states embraces this new
technology this technology is a freedom
technology it embodies everything about
the american ethos and values
it gives sovereignty and power back to
the individual it allows them to be able
to conduct transactions and transfer
value as simply as they can communicate
on the internet that's the beauty of
bitcoin and the united states just got
handed a second gift from china china
earlier this year banned miners and
kicked them out of the country thank you
we appreciate it because now the united
states has been able to gain significant
market share in the mining ecosystem we
appreciate that that makes the united
states more important in this industry
the future nation that ends up being
able to embrace artificial intelligence
bitcoin and decentralized technologies
will be the dominant nation
and that is what we have to continue to
beat the drum on here at home
now if all of a sudden china's going to
take that binding that mining ban
they're going to double and triple down
on it and they're going to say things
like now all cryptocurrency transactions
are illegal
thank you
we appreciate it that is exactly how we
position ourselves so that we can win
now on top of this we've got senator pat
toomey who came out and basically said
exactly this this is a united states
senator who was able to come out and say
china's authoritarian crackdown on
crypto including bitcoin is a big
opportunity for the united states it's
also a reminder for our huge structural
advantage over china
and so here you have a u.s senator again
talking about the authoritarian
crackdown on crypto in china
and saying that bitcoin is a big
opportunity for the united states it's a
reminder that we have a structural
advantage over china open networks beat
closed networks freedom trumps
authoritarianism that is what we know
democracy is better than communism and
socialism if you don't believe in those
things then you have a lot of questions
to ask because you may not be a student
of history and you may not actually
believe in the same things that america
was built on that free market
competition on a global scale if there's
a game put us in the game and let us
compete
that ultimately is going to decide who
the winner is let's go compete because
i'll always bet on american
entrepreneurs innovators and investors
to win on the global stage and even
better than that is that the pull of
america the promise of the american
dream the ability for people to come to
this country regardless of where they
were born what wealth they have what
education they have who their parents or
friends are what language they speak
what their sex is what their religion is
what their other beliefs are
they're allowed to come to this country
and when they come here they have the
ability to pursue a life of health
wealth happiness and financial security
that is the american dream is you can
come from anywhere in the world you can
come here and you can build that life
for yourself it's because we believe
that the individual is going to put us
in a position to be successful and
ultimately what we are watching is the
united states
has to make a decision china just made
theirs there's a line in the sand now
china says this freedom technology we do
not want inside of our country we do not
believe
that it aligns with our ethos
america if we value freedom should
embrace bitcoin we should be the leader
on a global stage we should say to
ourselves this decentralized digital
technology will allow us to continue to
be economically prosperous and it will
put us ahead of everyone else in the
world that's the beauty of bitcoin but
bitcoin doesn't care bitcoin doesn't
care if china embraces it doesn't care
if the united states embraces it doesn't
care if any other country embraces or
pushes it away it is nation agnostic
it simply continues to produce block
after block after block of transactions
and that's the beauty of bitcoin is that
regardless of whether you like it you
hate it
you want it to succeed or fail
it just keeps producing block after
block after block
we have circle ceo jeremy elaire he had
a whole tweet thread
this morning talking about these very
issues he said first a message to us and
western policy makers on how to think
about china's approach to crypto and
blockchain china opposes the western
system of values built on openness
transparency privacy free market
competition and so forth he then went on
to say
the next slide here that we have uh he
then went on to say that the internet
itself has an expression of these values
and it is one of the reasons that china
has always fought to control the
internet these values are also deeply at
the core of crypto and blockchains
enshrining them into new economic and
governance infrastructure and then the
thread went on and continuously said
crypto in blockchain is an absolute
threat to systems that are built around
total control centralization of power
elimination of privacy etc which side of
this do we want to be on
and then he said in the west a
rules-based order based on open free
market and democratic principles has
provided a very strong foundation for
economic and governance systems and have
the best hope of being extended by
embracing open public blockchains and
digital assets and then he finished with
there are two modes of reacting to china
and the united states we can start with
fomo envy and a belief that we should be
more like them given their ability to
execute
or we can be a stoic and determined
outlook that believes in the open
internet be on the right side of history
embrace the open internet of value
and it may sound elementary it may sound
too simple but that ultimately is the
decision that we have at the same time
that we have politicians regulators the
incumbents etc all debating
rules written on a piece of paper
they're important we should take it
seriously we should make sure that the
right protections are in the market but
don't lose sight of the big picture
the united states has an opportunity to
further its position in the world to use
open technologies to use technologies
that usher in freedom and sovereignty
and if we squander the opportunity
we are no different
than the authoritarian dictatorships the
communist countries around the world
that continue
to say we do not want our citizens to
participate in this that's not the
american way that's not what got us here
and it sure as hell is not going to be
the winning strategy moving forward
what's up guys bang bang thanks so much
for watching the best business show
today if we're going to be the best
business show we obviously need the best
partner that's why the exclusive sponsor
the best business show is sofi they're
an all-in-one platform that allows you
to invest in all kinds of different
assets including stocks etfs crypto ipos
and they even have an automated
investing function if that's your thing
so before we start getting after it
again make sure that you go download
sofi you get an invest account and when
you make your first crypto trade
regardless of what you buy they'll give
you 10 in bitcoin for free it's that
simple head on over to sofi.com to get
started today thanks so much for
watching and i hope you come back and
watch more the best business show
tomorrow
[Music]